now it started during the pandemic to
get kids outside get them healthy and
now it's a full-fledged holiday effort
to collect Sports balls and raise funds
join me now founder and CEO of Greater
Youth Sports Association Devonte Woodson
thank you for being here as well as
Sarah goitz from Vegas sports Realtors
now you guys are here you've joined
together in this partnership to
basically help out all the kids here in
our community tell us a little bit about
this fundraiser and how people can get
involved yes so the holiday sports ball
drive it all started actually during a
pandemic when all the schools were
everything was shot so everything was
shut down my background is that I was a
PE teacher so I knew instantly like a
lot of the students that I would serve
in our low-income communities they
already knew like they didn't have
anything at home yeah they didn't have
access to these a lot of students come
to school that's where the equipment is
that's where you know the lunches and
all that stuff like schools are like
safe houses for at least
so knowing that I was like okay we got
to do something to get them exercising
at home and get them balls get them
equipment to their house because we're
trying to do exercises all this stuff
and it's like if you don't have balls
are they're going to do anything yeah
y'all run around and that's not no
that's not enough you need that team
effort that is a sporting event exactly
so we run a sports program at the school
so instead of you know uh being live we
couldn't be live with the kids so we're
like hey let's collect Sports balls and
then we could give them out to the youth
that need it so that way they can stay
active and enjoy like the sports even
though it's not live at least they could
play at home yeah they have the items so
um Devante and Sarah you guys teamed up
you are collecting these balls it is
Saturday and now I know we're just
looking at some video from the past two
events so you're collecting from 11 to 2
on Saturday and you want people to drop
off every kind of sporting ball so what
a volleyball soccer balls football yes
and and Sarah you were mentioning in the
break that there's going to be some uh
some local athletic celebrities there as
well you yes so we do a lot of work with
the athletes from UNLV on the football
team and on the basketball team and
we're really fortunate we're going to
have a couple guys show up from the
football team in Virginia that just
declared that they're going to be
entering the draft okay so we're super
excited the teams have been very
supportive of everything that we've been
doing so we're really looking forward to
it so that's awesome so this is going to
be a family-friendly event that
everybody can show up and and now as far
as the distribution of these items
that's not taking place Saturday that's
going to be another time correct yes so
Sarah here
um was able to I think she had a
background in fostered Youth and
everything like that so now we're going
to be actually donating the boss to
Foster Youth and also at risk youth in
our community too great okay so Folks at
home oh see you gotta get used to this I
know on Saturday we're running out of
time but this is what you're going to
donate you're going to go on Saturday 11
to 2 and it's at the location is
Windmill and 215. phase one Elite Sport
training wonderful okay guys we're gonna
put all this information on our website
please help out if you can get those
kids the the items that they need to
have some fun and be athletic and enjoy
that team that team feeling uh stick
around we've got more coming up after
the break Devante Sarah thanks for being
here